thank you for joining us America this is
the Dave Ramsey show we're glad you are
here
Dean is with us in Clarksville hi Dean
how are you I'm doing great
thanks for having from the Kop sure how
can I help you looking first off thank
you for your done you've done a lot for
my wife and on our financial aspect of
life I am 25 years old my wife is 23
we're making about three thousand
dollars a year and following your
principles we're debt free except for
thirty two thousand dollars on our how
our home I'm sorry you said three
thousand dollars you're making one
thousand we're making thirty thousand
dollars per year okay okay and I said
we're debt-free I said for thirty two
thousand dollars on our home okay good
cool
we're also wanting to save ten to
fifteen thousand dollars somewhere
around there for a car and the main
question that I have I've been working
for my dad since I was fourteen general
construction and I'd like to start
flipping houses so my question is how
about started at that time um well let's
back up one step if you're making thirty
two thousand I probably wouldn't have
fifteen thousand tied up in a car if
that's your household income because you
don't want more than half your annual
income tied up in things that are going
down in value which is cars so I
probably back the budget down on the car
a little bit but then back to your
flipping houses question as you know you
said you've been following some of our
stuff I don't borrow money and I teach
people not to borrow money so that means
flipping houses is a little difficult
from your situation because you'd have
to be going into debt to do it obviously
and I'm not going to sit set you up for
that it's actually how I went broke when
I was your age I was flipping houses and
I had three million dollars in debt on
house flips and the bank got sold into
the bank they called our notes and it
took you know two and a half years for
me to lose everything I owned I don't
want to put you on that gravy train it
ain't
gravy's not good so you know I just
don't want that plan for you so instead
what I would tell you to do is this one
is um if you have the ability to find a
house cheap enough that you could flip
it and make money on it then you have
the ability to tie that house up and
sell it to another investor that does
have money and so I actually made good
money doing that after I went broke I
had no credit and I had no money because
I'd gone through bankruptcy but I didn't
know how to dig up a deal and I had been
doing that so I would find a property in
foreclosure for instance let's just I'll
make up some numbers let's say I found a
$50,000 house and foreclosure and I
could buy it for 21 I did this a lot and
I would write a contract with the bike
that's with the owner to buy the house
in the next five days for twenty one
thousand subject to my partner's
agreement contingent upon my partner's
agreement and then I would go and talk
to real estate investors that I knew
that one of the house of that type and
sell it to them and maybe I had twenty
one was the contract but I might sell it
to them for twenty six which is still a
great deal on a fifty thousand dollar
house but I'm making five thousand bucks
on the spread on the contract and I paid
nothing I didn't tell you I never bought
it I just sold the contract sold the
position and then the another investor
went in and bought it now one of the
reasons you're wanting to flip houses is
because you know how to do construction
right that's correct
yeah and that plan that I just outlined
doesn't involve you doing any
construction what you've got to be
careful of in the house flipping
business when you do construction is you
don't want to buy a house go into debt
and you go in there with your sweat and
fix the house up and then only make
wages that you would have made working
for somebody else fixing their house up
same if you go to work for somebody
doing a remodel job they'll pay you to
do that right and you'll make a profit
and you don't have to go in debt to work
for you know Joe and do fix-up Joe's
house over here he'll pay you you know
your construction costs
as a prophet and if you don't make your
wages plus a profit that you would have
made on a regular job plus make money on
the investment then you didn't really
make money on the house flip you just
are buying a house so you have a remodel
job and you can get remodel jobs without
buying houses and give them for other
people so make sure you're not just
paying yourself out wages when you're
doing your own work like that I know a
lot of guys that swing a hammer and you
know know how to use a paintbrush that
have fooled themselves into thinking
they're making money on the houses and
really all they're making money's on the
remodel and if you're not making more
than you would have made doing the
remodel for somebody else then you don't
need to be doing the house deal and you
know they'll say oh well I can go in and
I can fix it up for X or Y yeah well
you're not counting profit on your
remodel job and you would have made it
that profit had you been working for
somebody else on a remodel job so make
sure you don't make that mathematical
mistake in your estimates on your and on
your business plan on your flips so I
would start out just doing some flips
and get some money piled up that you
didn't own like I was talking about and
then once you get some money piled up
and if you want to some side remodel
jobs for some people do that and if you
want start working for some real estate
investors do that or maybe you go in
with somebody that's a real estate
investor and they give you a piece of
the profit in return for you doing the
remodel and they buy the house with
their money in that way you're not in
debt there's a lot of ways to skin this
cat rather than you're just going down
the bank and borrowing money to flip
houses which is a really good way to go
bankrupt not just because I did it but
because a whole lot of people flip this
house is bankrupt more people than just
about any other program out there and
it's just not as easy as it looks
and so you get in there and actually do
some flips do some other stuff and learn
the business and then when you've
actually got real money that you put
into the deal you'll do a lot better
deals because you'll have some
experience under your belt
hey guys Rachel Cruz here hope you
enjoyed that video from the Dave Ramsey
show if you want to watch another great
video check out my video
three things you should consider renting
right over here or click the link in the
description below
you